this is a video about how everything in
the martial arts sucks iido sucks MMA
sucks all the martial arts suck
everything's terrible you know if you
look around the internet everyone's got
opinion about why something sucks
everybody loves out it's terrible oh is
the system so bad um if you watched my
previous video I discussed a little bit
about what Marshal art systems are so if
you watch that and understood what I was
talking about you can kind of see that
it's really silly to say that system
sucks you know there are systems that
are better at one thing than another
thing um and it's possible that a system
was poorly put together but um generally
for most of the the systems at large
that we're going to be talking about uh
not the not smaller systems that
recently came about but larger systems
um they don't suck they're they are
designed to do what they're designed to
do and if you understand that it works
well for you and if you don't understand
that it doesn't work well for you uh and
it's that simple um but people tend to
say stuff sucks you know so like I
practice iido and all the time people
love to tell me how iido sucks oh it's
terrible oh you don't know how to clench
fight you don't know how to box you
don't know how to blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah well the real truth is
iido is not concerned with clinch
fighting it's not concerned with boxing
so uh when you're holding those things
up it's no different than me saying you
know like uh boxing sucks Western boxing
sucks because uh you don't learn how to
sail a sailboat with it right it's like
well why would I expect Western boxing
to teach me how to sail a sailboat
you're stupid for telling me that and
that's exactly the way I feel when
people talk about how iido sucks because
you can't box with it or how iido sucks
because you can't grapple with it or how
iido sucks because you can't throw uh
like you would in Judo or something with
it and then you know I say all those
things and people go well if it sucks at
all three of those things then it must
just suck at fighting because that's all
fighting it's like well there's an awful
lot to fighting um there's awful lot to
conflict that's way outside of of
throwing and striking and grappling
which is you know the big three people
tend to think about when you think about
martial arts like well either it's a
striking art or it's a throwing art or
it's a grappling art and that's all
there is to it right well no that's not
all there is to it you know kindo
doesn't teach you how to box it doesn't
teach you how to Grapple and it doesn't
teach you how to throw uh yet uh a good
Koka will definitely defeat other sport
martial artists within its context of
kindo uh now if the kindo guy tries to
box with a boxer he'll lose of course he
will um because he doesn't study boxing
uh kindo has nothing to do with boxing
and similar to iido um one of the
reasons that I would agree uh with
people that a lot of iido sucks is
there's not um a live training practice
to it so uh you know live training is
very very important um and a lot of iido
practitioners especially in recent times
have really done some work to try and
get uh life practice into iido and let's
not forget that shodokan iido to meu uh
has um and I know some people don't like
calling it that I'm sorry um has a live
practice and has had a live practice for
a very very long time so it's not that
all iido is is void you know um so uh
that's you know iido sucks I hear that
all the time you know well MMA sucks too
right I remember uh when I was in my 20s
and studying MMA uh a guy came up to me
and and said oh do you study martial
arts and I said yeah and he said what
are you studying I said oh Brazilian
jiu-jitsu and and some some different
styles of boxing uh and he was like oh
do you do MMA and I said yeah and he was
like oh well what would you do if I had
my friends Smith and Wesson with me you
know and I remember when he said that to
me I just looked at him like he was
crazy you know I was like what the hell
is this guy talking about um but he was
pointing out something very valid to me
and it's like well within the realm of
gunfights if I have a gun and you don't
it doesn't matter what you're trained in
um in my perfect context you won't win
right and uh you know it seems like a
silly thing to say to me because it's
like well I don't I don't worry about
fighting with guns you know and and
definitely at the time I wasn't worried
about uh Gunplay wasn't wasn't really a
major consideration of mine um but this
guy was and to this guy it was like well
why should I learn to box when I could
get a gun and use a gun you know and you
hear people say this kind of stuff about
martial arts all the time you know like
well now that Firearms exist uh why
should martial arts exist and it's like
well I mean you know swords existed a
long time ago and we still have martial
arts knives existed a long time ago we
still have martial arts rocks existed a
long time ago and we still have martial
arts right uh martial arts are developed
around the weapons so um you know pistol
craft is definitely a martial art right
is is an art form being able to Under
Pressure pull out your weapon put your
front sights on something and squeeze
the trigger and make sure you understand
what's behind your Target and what's
around you and being able to do that in
a a very fast Manner and being able to
scan for other potential targets that is
definitely a martial art um and it might
not be one that you're interested in
studying and that's okay and so if if
that isn't something you're interested
in studying then you know you could very
easily say well it's stupid to study uh
pistol craft because who carries a
pistol right not many people carry a
pistol well some people do and those
people are interested in learning to use
that people some people have no interest
in learning to use a pistol and so they
learn unarmed methods right some people
are interested in using blades or all
kinds of different stuff um and
basically you choose systems based on
what you're interested in learning so
any system sucks when compared to other
things you know you MMA sucks if I got a
gun right well guns suck if you don't
have one right so training with a gun
sucks if you don't happen to have one
um all these different different ideas
come into play somewhere in the world
and it's just it's your job as a martial
art to understand um where those ideas
come into play so uh don't be so quick
to say how something sucks right or at
least at the very least understand that
everything sucks right everything sucks
all martial art systems suck out of
context all martial art systems are
absolutely terrible right so you know I
don't know one martial art system in the
world that can teach you about sailing a
boat right and if sailing a boat is what
you're interested in learning to do well
then you shouldn't study martial arts
and it's that simple right and if you do
want to learn about conflict then you
should study martial arts and you should
probably study a lot of martial arts
because conflict is a huge area right if
you're seriously St uh interested in
studying the martial arts and and
understanding what conflict's about
there's a lot to understand so you
should get out there and check out all
the different systems out there and just
remember they all suck in one way or
another but most of them are probably
really good too and uh and warrant your
your attention all right so that's just
a little bit I wanted to talk about how
much Hearts suck all right take care I'm
Chris H